Horace Johnson dropping into a homeless
shelter just up the road through Downing
Street he wants to get on with his
domestic agenda but we're back to brexit
today as the PM laid out his blueprint
for trade talks with the EU it is a
negotiation though you will have to make
some concessions you accept that but
this is this is say that we want a we
want a great free trade deal it's that
to be done we're very optimistic and we
want a great relationship with our with
our friends but his idea of a great
relationship very different to that of
Teresa May he wants a free trade deal
that removes tariffs and quotas for
goods but with checks at our borders and
the government will walk away in June if
it doesn't look like it's getting its
way we're confident that we will be able
to make progress but of course both
sides will take stock in June and that
will be an opportunity for both sides to
see if appropriate progress has been
made both sides very far apart right now
a big barrier is Brussels demand that
the UK agreed to follow common rules and
standards it wants fair competition and
to use EU standards as a reference point
but for the UK government brexit means
taking back control of laws number 10
clear we will not agree to any
obligations for our laws to be aligned
to the --use Boris Johnson's a brexit
ear who's made British sovereignty his
redline in these trade talks yes he
wants a basic free trade deal by the end
of the year but he'll settle for a no
trade deal exit if the EU insists that
the UK signs up to its rulebook he's
just not going to do it that much is
clear
but what's still the big unknown what it
means for the economy the trade offs not
yet fleshed out by the government Boris
Johnson approach is to say we're leaving
the EU we're going to go for a model
that the EU acknowledges is on the table
so a Canada style free trade agreement
and yes there's going to be an economic
cost but it's worth it because we'll
have the freedom to intervene in the
economy as we see fit and the freedom to
strike new free trade agreements and in
the long run it will be worth it trust
us mr. Johnson says he's optimistic
Brussels be
realistic we will as we have done during
the negotiations on the withdrawal
agreement continue to inform people as
well as businesses about what
preparedness measures would be necessary
in the event of no deal each side
publishing trade terms this week but
their positions are not set in stone far
apart for now with just four months to
close the gap both sides say a deal is
possible but these talks will be tough
Beth Rigby Sky News Westminster